so search engine of optimization or
organic search we have a mixture of paid
and free so there's a lot of different
platforms but if you're focusing on SEO
you certainly need to use an SEO
platform so there's semm Rush okay you
also have Google search console which is
free so if you don't have a SEO platform
you definitely need to be using Google
search console and so we'll take a
closer look at that there's Google
Keyword Planner which is actually
situated under Google ads and so if
you're running Google campaigns on
Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called Keyword Planner and if
you know anything about SEO you'll know
that using Google's Keyword Planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
MZ is a premium tool meaning they have a
free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another SEO
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool in screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool in HRS
that help us with all aspects of SEO
primarily focusing on off page so these
are just some examples that we're going
to hone in on but this is just a small
subset of what really is available out
there in the market so let's go ahead
and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume and low
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's Keyword
Planner so here I am I'm in Google's
Keyword Planner and as I mentioned
before Google's Keyword Planner is
situated under Google ad okay so you
have to have a Google ads account to use
Google's keyboard planner and so when
you're in Google ads you simply go to
tools and then under Tools you're going
to select Keyword Planner so what we
want to do is look for keywords we're
focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so let's just use one of the
examples that Google's given us here
mail delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if I wanted to
but I'm asking Google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
I'm going to click click get results
notice I can add another key if I wanted
to but I'm just going to stick with one
keyword but there are certainly other
keywords that I can certainly hone in on
if mail delivery is my business and so
let's just hone in on that one keyword
mail delivery we want to be found
organically for that keyword so what
Google Keyword Planner does is not only
give us the keyword and other keywords
relevant to that but it gives us the
average monthly search volumes and this
is an average over the course of the
last 12 months and notice here I get a a
column for competition so I'm able to
see whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
an extra Edge when you're choosing
keywords you can get a sense of what the
keyword May cost if you wanted to bid on
that for paid search so for mail
delivery I can see it's anywhere between
$746 and at the top of the page high
range
$16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm going to try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit High well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know a dollar to $3 okay I
could see some other ones that are even
lower than the $7 they're suggesting so
that's a indication that the keyword is
highly competitive so the idea here
using Google's Keyword Planner is one we
want to get an idea of what other
keywords are out there that are relevant
so it helps stimulate some ideas for
relevancy two we can get an average
monthly search volume so we want to know
on average over the past 12 months how
many search queries I can expect from
this keyword and then three I can get a
sense of the competition how competitive
is this keyword so if I try to optimize
for this keyword and I want to rank for
organ Tech Al is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
Texas I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total us so you
have settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a Moz account so I
logged into MZ and MZ has a called
keyword Explorer so if I use that same
keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask
MZ to give me some data on that keyword
so this is for the entire United States
and again I can change that if I wanted
to okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what Ma
is telling me hey for this keyword in
the entire United States I'm looking at
anywhere from
115,000 to 30,000 on monthly volume now
what Ma does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between one and 100 and so I
can see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's 100 it's very difficult and
then that means you have a lot of
competitors who are optimizing for this
keyword that are ranking for this
keyword and so mod gives us the volume
they give us the competition and they
just like Google's Keyword Planner gives
us some other keywords that we can
potentially hone in on so here I could
see keyword delivery plans delivery
services Etc so I can see a lot more
suggestions than what's listed here so
MZ delivers a bunch of other analysis uh
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so MZ is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to to Mo
related to SEO for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use Google's Keyword
Planner because maybe you're not running
Google ads you can always use Moz now
remember MZ has basically a freemium
version meaning you can sign up for a
free account and you can sign up for a
free account as a test trial and you
could test it for a period of days and
leverage its tools during that free
trial to get a better sense of how these
tools work so we want to be able to use
mods we want to be able to use Google's
Keyword Planner not only to search for
all those relevant keywords available to
you but we want to be able to choose
keywords with high volume and low
difficulty low competition we also want
to select primary and second keywords
wisely so remember when you optimize
you're optimizing a page for more than
one keyword so you want to be able to
have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high High search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Mo gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
uh to get more specific details about
using SEO tools for keyword research and
all about keyword research in general
for SEO so let's talk about some other
reasons under SEO why we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze linking to our web page
okay which ones are good which ones are
not good okay we also want to perform
some competitor analysis so these are
some of the reasons why other than
keyword research why would would we use
some of these SEO tools so we have tools
available to us some Majestic HRS again
mods let's take a look at Google search
console and I want to hone in on Google
search console because it is free and
it's a must if you're going to work on
SEO you need to be working in Google
search console and so the whole key
behind Google search console is you have
a website and you need to get that site
verified once it's verified once Google
can recognize that you are associated
with this website then you're going to
be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so so what does coverage
mean well going back to what we just
said we want to be able to understand
how Google's crawling and indexing our
pages and so what Google does is through
this platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I could see I
have some issues with 112 pages
and some of those issues are listed down
here so there could be a crawl issue a
44 you know redirect okay so you could
see there's some five unique issues
across 112 pages so here I could see
submitted URL marked no index there's a
100 of those pages we have some redirect
errors there's seven pages that you know
fall victim to this error and so we can
really hone in on what the ER is and
address the error okay so if Google's
telling us hey this is an issue and you
want that page indexed by Google then we
should probably address the error and so
that's the great thing here about going
into Google search console is you can
under index go to coverage and get a
sense of what Google's indexing and what
they're not indexing so these are the
errors I can see they've certainly were
able to crawl an index
9,115 p
uh they were able to crawl okay and they
excluded
54,000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
pages inex next we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling us firsthand what the issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so you have an opportunity to
submit a Sit map and a Sit map is just a
formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it sitemap.xml XML being the
format so once you have this file you're
just going to let Google know that that
file exists so you're going to enter in
the sitemap URL so if it's in the root
directory all you're going to do is type
in sitemap.xml and click submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what Google's going to do is say
hey look we see you submitted this and
we last read it a couple days ago and we
could see that we discovered 1,419 URLs
so I can go back under coverage and I
can see some of the issues that they
found but if I go back under sit Maps I
can see that these are the URLs they
discovered via the sit map and so the
whole point of a Sit map is we want to
be able to get and push the URLs to
Google not have Google come to our site
and discover them so this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with Google all the URL
that you have on your site that you want
Google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report so Google is a
staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on on mobile so they begin it
on mobile and they may end it on mobile
so if they don't end it on mobile then
you know perhaps they'll go into a store
or perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fars Via
Mobile and when I say fars Via Mobile is
it mobile friendly is it responsive is
it loading quick enough you know is it
formatted to Google standards and so if
there are any issues Google's going to
let you know what those issues are so
here I could see Google's recognized 206
pages with four different issues okay so
here I can see what those issues are
just like the coverage issues we can see
specifically what they are and so here I
can see for 206 Pages text too small to
read click elements too close together
the viewport not set to div device WID
and then content wider than the screen
so there's 10 pages that fit under this
eror and if I actually click on it the
error I can see what those 10 pages are
and so when we're done we can actually
when we address the issues we can
actually have Google validate whether
the fix has been made so you can
definitely use this as a means of
communicating directly with Google
telling Google look I see what the
issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is is important because if you can
communicate with Google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these Pages index
quicker um so if you ignore the issues
and the errors especially for mobile
then you stand the chance of your pages
not getting index so the mobile
usability report to me is an important
report because we want to better
understand
whether Google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get Google valid them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report in
Google search conso tells us what pages
have the most links okay so here we can
see the homepage has 26,000 plus links
if we hone in on interior page Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I can see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console is giving me kind of an
overview of what my linking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages of my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so i' be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
I think of interest in Google search
console and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you can link up
with Google analytics so you could see
the same report in analytics if you're
able to link up Google search console
with analytics and you should be able to
do that all you need to do is make sure
you use the same email address that you
use for analytics and search console so
it needs to be the same email address
you could certainly link up the two and
and have this data imported into Google
analytics so what is this data that
we're talking about well it's called
performance so what we can actually see
is the queries the actual queries people
are typing in to Google so when they're
typing them into Google we can actually
see how many Impressions the keyword
queries received and how many clicks the
keyword queries received and then I can
see click the rate and average position
Okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword on the first line I
could see over the course of the last 3
months it received
29,285 Impressions so what does that
mean that means this keyword was used at
Le or typed in as a query at least that
many times and that's how many times my
listing appeared in the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209,000 plus times
this site received 120,000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click theate
all you would need to do and Google can
obviously do this for you is you would
simply just divide the 2092979267
[Music]
so over half of the clicks occur when
this listing appears for this keyword
okay so we can get a sense of the click
the rate for each one okay and you could
simply just use the filtering here now
we can also see average position okay so
we could see a little bit more than that
too we can go from queries to Pages we
can go from pages to countries so we get
a sense of how many Impressions and
clicks I'm receiving by country and
importantly we can see by device so here
I can see a majority of the people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop now I
mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I see
the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my Impressions my click theate buy
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when I
link up Google search console with
analytics I'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we are going to use these
SEO tools available to us and so we
already listed a number of different
reasons ranging from sit maps to keyword
research but we also want to hone in on
you know what domains are driving links
to our site so I showed you an example
in search console we also want to hey
maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
clickthrough rates and Impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like MZ you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a MZ account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
can certainly see where they rank the
great thing about MZ is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and on page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score out
of one and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insight sites as
to how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm
going to be act able to see the actual
domains pointing to my scite as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look at
all the domains that are linking to me
and then I can highlight the ones that
have poor domain Authority what Moz even
takes it a step further they also give
me a Spam score so Moz is able to
measure how spammy a website is so if I
have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score score
then I probably want to disavow myself
from that site and so I can use this
report here you could see here as I keep
going down for example I can see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16% so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only who's link
linking to me meaning domain but how
many linking domains does that domain
have what's the spam score of that
domain what's the domain authority of
that domain and then I can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about backlinks domain Authority spam
Etc everything you need to use in order
to measure off page SEO so that's the
great thing about m is they have not
only on page SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a fremium so to speak
so here you could see if you just go to
m.com free-- tools you'll be able to to
use some of these tools available to you
not just for SEO but also for local SEO
as well so here you like some of these
tools you can start your free 30-day
trial so I use and lean on M A lot for
all that it has to offer from choosing
keywords to rankings report to checking
issues on my website to even checking
who's linking to me so this fits in the
mold with everything I need to do for
SEO so in addition to that keyword
research video you could certainly lean
on some other webinars that we've done
in the past on SEO so we've done a
webinar on SEO tools and we've also done
a webinar on SEO tips and tricks so if
you want any more information about the
tools we covered or SEO in general take
a look at those two videos and check
them out and that should kind of
complement what we talked about with
using some of the tools Google's Keyword
Planner uh MZ and Google search console
okay let's switch over to email
marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us in the form of reporting in the
form of Platforms in the form of you
know tools that really help us go from A
to Z on our email choosing you know what
email to send out to creating a list to
measuring how the email campaign went
and so we could start with MailChimp
because MailChimp is a premium version
whenever we say premium meaning they
have a free trial available then you're
expected to upgrade but you know
MailChimp to me is a tool I use I like
the interface very easy for beginners so
we're going to take a look at MailChimp
but there are certainly many others
available you know Mar is a good tool
you know Mar is a good tool because if
you have a business and you're trying to
funnel people through your pipeline so
to speak meaning they they sign up as a
lead and you want to nurture that lead
from the beginning to the end meaning at
the end they're actually going to turn
around and purchase well Mar is a good
tool for you to use because you can then
set up trip campaigns or also known as
email campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about maretto it has drip campaign
available along with some other features
there's HubSpot is a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to AB testing to social to you
know email so this is another premium
tool that you could use you have another
premium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convert kit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a f favorite
email marketing tool that you use
Constant Contact vertical response there
plenty out there Emma you know feel free
to to note that in the comment section
below this video I'm curious as to how
many people actually use you know
different tools because there are so
literally so many email marketing tools
out there why because email marketing
has been around probably the longest
amongst all the other digital marketing
channels and a lot of people use email
on a on a daily basis so it's no wonder
why there's just so many tools available
and so with these tools you could
certainly send bulk emails now in the
case of marato you could send emails to
a segmented audience and so that's
actually what you want to do as a
strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to use an tool that's going to be able
to segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like I
mentioned with maretto you want a
workflow set up where hey if somebody
does this you're sending email B Etc so
you want a email marketing tool that's
flexible enough to handle what your
business strategy and goals are okay so
you want to be able to also use a tool
that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to manage your list
appropriately meaning if you have 10,000
users emails in a list you want to be
able to manage them accordingly you know
break them up or or have sub list so to
speak and then most importantly you want
to make sure you have a platform that
not only does it's tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of of recipients clicked on your email
what links do they click on you know
which which emails bounce so you want
some detailed insights
right in the platform that you're using
it just makes it more simpler and easier
and more effective to manage you
certainly want to create the smart
automated campaigns meaning you don't
even have to send out the email and then
you want to be able to have some
flexibility to set up email delivery
based on a specific time and day so
these tools also allow you to you
sigment contacts based on geolocation
you want to be able to use a tool that
allows for multivariant testing again
you want to analyze performance and
optimize campaigns you want to trigger
automatic responses somebody purchases
something are you using a tool that will
automatically send that email out so
these are all the reasons why you would
use an email marketing tool so let's
dive in and take a look at an example
and we're going to use MailChimp as our
example today so let's dive in and take
a look at MailChimp so with MailChimp
once you log in you know you're going to
be able to see some historical campaigns
that you sent out or you're going to be
able to create your own campaign and so
this is kind of under campaigns you can
kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on August 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to you know pick and
choose who we're sending this to who
it's from what the subject line is and
then we can certainly design the email
so if we click design email again this
is important because with email
marketing you want to be able to cater
your email to your intended audience so
if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with the intended audience and so
here you can see MailChimp allows us to
do that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste your code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reporting okay
so yes it is easy to choose a template
and map that template to your audience
but I really like the reports that they
have to offer so you know here you could
see there's some list that we've sent to
and we choose one of our audience list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so here I could see
this email that was sent out in June I
could see it was sent to 95,000 plus
subscribers okay of the subscribers I
saw 2,000 plus open it and 157 clicks so
I can view this report in more detail
just by clicking on view report so again
we want an email platform that's going
to be able to give us some detailed
information about how that email
campaign performed and so so I can get
down really to the nitty-gritty I can
actually see you know on the content
what was clicked and what wasn't clicked
so here I sent two different subject
lines so I'm able to compare the two
against one another okay so I can really
go into detail about one of them here so
if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16% I
only have had an open rate of 2.5% so
the industry average is 18% and so here
I'm able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers with
the most opens I can link social to it
if I want to and then I can see
geographic information
so the point being is MailChimp really
goes into some nice detail here about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is too with
the mailchip you can link it with Google
analytics you can link it with Ecommerce
okay so if you have an email and you're
you're selling products and somebody
purchased that product MailChimp is able
to integrate in with your shopping
Commerce platform for example woo
Commerce so some somebody did purchase
you can send out that thank you email
MailChimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did click on a link go to
your shopping cart add something to the
shopping cart and then abandon the cart
you know mailchip allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so MailChimp is flexible and that's what
you want in a email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed report on your different
campaigns for that audience so that's
MailChimp in summary and so most email
platforms do a lot of the similar
features or have some of the similar
features but that's what you ideally
want to look for in an email marketing
platform so here's a tool that doesn't
get talked about enough when it comes to
email marketing and that's Google's URL
Builder and the reason why we're going
to talk about this tool today is because
most most people in the US use Google
analytics as their web Analytics tool
and the one thing about Google analytics
is it allows you to track different
campaigns so if you're doing
pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
mailchip or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have a URL
that says visit Florida and I'm going to
send out an email I have up to five
parameters that I can use okay so here's
my email or URL that I'm using in the
email so I have up to five parameters
that I can use to track this particular
email so let's go through through some
of those parameters so the first one is
campaign source so what's the source of
the campaign well we could certainly
identify mail champ if we're using mail
champ as the source now the the thing
about the URL Builders you always want
to use lower case because Google
analytics is case sensitive so as a rule
of thumb just stick with a lower case so
our source is going to be MailChimp
because that's the platform we're using
if you're using you know Constant
Contact or vertical response or you know
some of these other one convert kit then
go ahead and put in that platform as the
source now for the medium which is the
means in which we're driving traffic to
the site let's go ahead and put in email
because that's what we're using to drive
traffic to this particular page now
what's the campaign name well we're in
summer so we're going to call this the
summer promo so the summer promo here is
visit Florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to Florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice I got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so Google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for camp
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email I would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do I say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say you have 10,000 recipients I want to
be able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's going to get
subject line one and one segment that's
going to get subject line two so in this
case I'm going to put whatever subject
line one is in the campaign content
field so now I have four parameters and
once I've entered in my variables in
those parameter Fields I now have a
revised or pended URL so my original URL
was visit
florida.com and- us Florida bees. HTML
my original URL I've now appended that
with some UTM parameters and now I see
my original URL appended with the UTM
parameters based on those variables so I
can copy it just by clicking the copy
URL I can go to my browser I can paste
that URL in there and I want to check to
see if it works so here I could see this
particular page loaded Florida beaches
with my etm parameters appended to the
URL so that's for the first first
subject line that's for the audience
that's going to get the first subject
line I want to do another one for the
second subject line so now I'm going to
change my campaign content parameter to
subject
Line2 I'm going to copy that URL I'm
going to check it okay so I can see that
the page loads with those UTM parameters
and so now what am I going to do I'm
going to use the first URL and the
second URL in my email okay so any link
that I have in this case I'm using
subject line two so for the email with
the second subject line going to that
segmented audience this is the link I'm
going to use in the email so if you have
one or two or three links in the email
this is the URL you're going to use
because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see that
that click in Google analytics so if I
jump over to Google analy analytics
after I sent out my email I'm going to
go to acquisition I'm going to go to
campaigns I'm going to go to all
campaigns now based on the variables I
put into my parameters meaning Source
medium campaign name content or term
that's what I'm going to look for in
Google analytics so we could start with
source and medium so if I click on
source and medium as my primary
Dimension here I can see MailChimp and
the actual date was used as part of the
variable for for source and then what
can I see the medium being email so now
I can see for this email that was sent
out in MailChimp in May I can see how
many users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conversions so we
could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email drove in traffic and conversions
and if I'm doing subject line testing I
can choose content as my parameter so
here I'm going to change it to content
and now I can see the subject lines in
this case if I go back to my source
medium I'm going to be able to see what
subject lines from my email emils
generated the most traffic and not only
the most traffic but also conversions so
that's the whole point behind using the
URL Builder again you're taking a URL
that you're going to use an email and
then you're going to pan that URL with
different parameters campaign Source
campaign medium campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those those parameters you're going
to get an appended URL which you can
then use in your email so when the email
gets sent you're going to go back over
to Google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that Medium of that
content I.E subject line and so that's
why the URL build is so important
because MailChimp gives us some good
insight as to how the email performed in
terms of open and click rates but what
we really want to see is how that
campaign performed once it drove traffic
to my website so that's the whole idea
behind the URL Builder if you're using
Google analytics you'll be able to use
the URL Builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
TOS kind of the Cent Central focal point
of all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google analytics Google
analytics is a premium meaning that they
have a free version that you can use
there is also a paid version of Google
analytics but given the Advent of Google
it's popularity especially in the United
States a majority of users are using the
free version of Google analytics so it's
a very popular tool especially for
marketers but there are also other tools
available so it's not just Google so we
have Adobe analytics which is also
fremium you have kiss metric you have
spring metrics you have YouTube
analytics which is part of Google but
YouTube has its own separate analytics
insights so a lot of these as you can
see are free to use they're available no
reason why you should not be using uh an
Analytics tool to measure your marketing
campaigns or website behavior and why
would we want to use these tools again
well again we want to really measure
Behavior we want to measure what's going
on with our website so we want to be
able to identify the location of where
our website visitors are coming from and
a lot of these analytics tools use IP
address to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
Target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website Behavior so we get traffic to
the website what are they doing how long
are they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use web
analytics to to measure how successful
our website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50% new and 50%
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors CU that means more traffic so
you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines or index
in your pages and your pages are being
found via the search engines and so you
want to be able to measure how much
traffic you're actually generating from
those search engines we talked about
this with email marketing UTM tracking
so if you set up email campaigns or non-
gooogle campaigns you want to use UTM
tracking and Google analytics and other
analytics tools but specifically Google
analytics will help you see the results
of your camp aigns if they're tracked
with UTM tracking so that's another good
reason why to use a a web Analytics tool
probably most importantly amongst all
these bullet points is our goals our
website conversions we want to be able
to see how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel spring
metrics you know they all work in a
similar fashion in that they're really
measuring website behavior and so if
we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience in Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website right
but they are going to say that somebody
from San Francisco California came to
the website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning user so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but they are providing you
with a good picture of who is coming and
when I say picture we have to paint that
picture and so if we look at say
demographics for example and I go to
demographics overview here's a picture
I'm painting well I can see that 25 to
34 year olds are the majority of the age
group that is coming to my website okay
I can see on the gender side of it I can
see that 63% of my traffic and again
this is year to date that I'm looking at
is coming to my website so 2/3 of my
traffic is female 1/3 male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34 so I'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well I can
also look at Geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
I go to location under goo I'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
I can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I could see
United States is is the primary driver
but not by much so we have 16 almost
177% from the US and then 16% from
Argentina 133% from Mexico 10% from
India so we have a nice mix of traffic
from different locations in the world
coming to our website so that's Geo but
more importantly let's take a look at
mobile so if we get a mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they on a desktop or laptop are they
using their mobile device are they using
a tablet and so Google analytics breaks
it down very nice for you and so we
could see percentages and actual numbers
by device category and so in this case I
can see year to date I can see 62% are
coming from desktop 35% are coming from
mobile and so that's important because
most people start their Journey from
mobile and that is growing and and
that's going to continue to grow so you
want to keep an eye on mobile so to me
this is one of the more important
reports under audience because people
who come from Mobile have a different
not only experience because the website
should be responsive to the mobile
device but their mindset is going to be
different they're actively looking for
something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for Direct or
they may just call you so the experience
is a lot different on mobile so we want
to hone in on the growth of mobile okay
so to me this is one of the more
important reports in Google analytics
especially under audience so let's move
on to acquisition so acquisition
reporting tells us how the traffic was
driven to the website so if audience
tells us who is coming to the website
acquisition tells us how that traffic
got to the website and so really what
you want to do is get a sense of what
channels what marketing channels are
driving traffic so remember we talked
about organic search well those search
engines are indexing your pages well how
much of that traffic from the search
engines is actually coming to your site
and I'm a Believer in if organic search
is the primary driver of traffic then
you have a pretty healthy website CU
that means the search engines are
indexing your p Pages people are
searching for something related to your
business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we can see it
broken down by Channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72% of my traffic and this is year to
dat then I can see paid search then I
can see direct which means Somebody went
directly to the site I could see
referral email social then I could see
more paid search broken out so these are
the different marketing channels now
analytics allows you to look at a
specific source and medium so the source
would be the actual website or search
engine in the medium would differentiate
how that traffic actually got to the
site so if we're talking about a search
engine did they come to the site via
paid search or did they come to the site
via organic search and so all we need to
do is change our primary Dimension from
default Channel grouping to source and
medium and we can see specifically the
breakout of the different sources and
mediums driving traffic to the site so
here I can see Google organic at
71% and then Google CPC or CA per click
at 15 16% of our traffic so then I can
look down I can see email in here being
organic I could see some referring sites
I could see some social in terms of
mobile Facebook okay so we could see a
mix of the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at Channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non Google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaigns drove traffic
to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search conso
so we looked at search console earlier
when we talked about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google Google analytics
well here's search console and we could
see queries devices landing pages
countries so all the performance metrics
that we could see in search console
because we have it linked up with
analytics we could see it right here so
this gives us a nice snapshot of what
keywords are driving traffic to the site
organically I could see The Impressions
I could see the clicks then I could see
the click duray and then the average
position so in theory the higher
something ranks the more traffic you're
going to get so that's the idea behind
it we want to make sure that we're
ranking for our coveted keywords and if
we are we want to be able to measure how
many times our listing was seen and how
many times it was clicked so that's the
great thing about you know Google they
have a family of products and those
products tend to talk to one another in
the form of Google search console and
Google ads you can connect them directly
to Google analytics so let's move from
acquisition to behavior so here in
Behavior we have a number of different
reports so Behavior tells us once the
traffic actually arrived at the website
how are they behaving and so really what
I would do is from there go to site
content all pages and so this gives us
an idea of how many pages were actually
viewed so site content all Pages tells
us what page and how many times it was
viewed during a period of time and again
we're looking at year to dat so I can
see engagement related metrics
associated with a page so this
particular page here on line one I could
see how many page views unique page
views which is equal to sessions so I
can have a session come to the website
and look at a page multiple times in
that session I could see the average
time the person has spent on a page and
I can also see the balce rate so a balce
rate indicates that they arrived on the
page and didn't go any further they left
the website from that page that they
arrived on and so I can also see
percentage of exits meaning what page
did people exit the site from so these
are all engagement related metrics so
here is where I want to react and
optimize my website performance so I if
I see a page not performing well meaning
it has a high bounce rate or maybe low
time on page then I'm probably going to
optimize it meaning test it or change it
to improve performance so these are all
pages but I could certainly look at Lany
pages okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it so a landing page means
that somebody came from organic search
or paid search or another Channel landed
on this page so here I can see this
particular page on line one had
4,970 sessions okay and I can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because pages and
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we we
want to go to site speed we want to look
at how fast or how slow our Pages load
so this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if a page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you could see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address
when trying to improve the page load
time of that particular page so here I
could see there's some server response
time issues image sizes probably need to
be resized I can remove unused CSS okay
so there are a lot of different things I
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop I can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift in page low time we
see a lift in page low time we're going
to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me sight speed
is an important report under Behavior
now one more report here that I want to
point out under behavior is events and
to me events are important so if you're
trying to measure engagement on your
website you need to make sure you have
event tracking set up and when we talk
about event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a PDF
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here we could see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example I can see on line six video I
can see how many people actually watched
our video okay so here's the action
video start
okay so over this period of time I could
see I had 49 unique events 50 total so
that's how many people actually watch
the video and you can always revert to
label and that'll tell you what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure engagement so
if you go to events under behavior and
you don't see any events listed you
probably need to get that set up and
that is set up through Google tag
manager so what you want to do is you
want to be able to set up your events
through Google tag manager which is
another Google platform but you
certainly want to do that so that's
where you set up your events when you
set up your events for your website with
a category and action and label you'll
be able to measure those events in
analytics under Behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be a able to measure engagement so I'll
be able to see how many people came to
the site and how many people clicked on
a button downloaded a PDF uh submitted a
form uh played a video did whatever we
wanted them to do so events are
important so let's move from Behavior to
conversions and this is important
because we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website so analy itics
has four types of conversions so if I go
to admin down at the bottom and then I
go to goals I could see that I have four
different types of goals that I can use
now right now I have event related goals
set up for the website for this
particular website so we just talked
about event tracking so if you're
measuring a button click on your website
you can certainly turn that into a goal
and so all you need to do is tell
analytics hey this is the particular
category this is the particular action
so for example if I click on this
particular goal and take a look at it I
can see that we have a category set up
that anything that resembles donate now
okay or donate go ahead and fire this
event as a conversion okay so event is
one type of goal another type of goal is
destination so if somebody goes to to a
specific page like a confirmation page
we can turn that into a goal so here I
could see if somebody goes to donation
dasc confirmation then analytics is
going to fire that goal as a conversion
and we're going to see a conversion
against a different metric or different
dimension like Channel or audience okay
so destination is the second type of
goal the third type of goal is duration
so how long do somebody stay on my
website so in this example if they
stayed at least 1 minute and 30 seconds
or more then analytics is going to count
that as a goal conversion okay so
duration is the third type and then the
fourth type is pages per session okay so
if I look at this example here if a user
came to my website and looked at more
than three pages in that particular
session then analytics is going to fire
a goal conversion so four types of goals
you don't have to set up all four
different types my recommendation is at
least to have one goal set up if you're
not sure what goal to set up then at
least set up a duration or pages per
session okay so at least you can measure
how long somebody stays on your website
or how many pages they went to okay so
when you actually do have these goals
set up you can go back into conversions
we can go back into goals we can go back
into overview and we can measure our
goal completions over this period of
time so here I can see 313 goal
completions total with a goal conversion
rate of 1.88% and then I can see it
broken down by goal type so remember the
only goals I have available and set up
are event related goals so 69 newsletter
signups 156 donate click buttons I have
32 contact form submission
37 email click completions and then 11
phone number click completions so I can
measure engagement as a goal and so
goals generally are important to the
business so you want to make sure that
if you have a goal for your website then
you want to be able to set that up as a
goal in Google analytics so that way
when you're looking at example channels
if I go back to my channels report I can
then measure Channel by goal conversion
so these are all goals but if I want to
look at for example how many people from
organic search clicked on the Donate Now
button I could see that I could see year
to date
10,887 users which meant 11,000 sessions
76 clicked on that donate Now button and
that's comes out to
65% conversion rate okay so that's
important so you want to be able to
measure any Dimension whether that be
Channel Source medium keyword campaign
mobile device could be
demographic uh gender or age you want to
be able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in gole Google
analytics again audience acquisition
behavior and conversions there a lot of
data in Google analytics but you want to
be able to take advantage of the data in
order to improve website performance now
let's jump over to YouTube analytics
because if you have videos on YouTube if
you have a channel set up some playlist
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your videos
performing and so here I could see see
I'm in YouTube all I did was I went to
my account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube Studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
I could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8,600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over
177,000 and I've netted 48 subscribers
and this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click theough rate so here I
can see the different traffic sources so
29% came externally okay here I can see
25% came within YouTube itself I can see
how many times a video was viewed and
played via playlist via suggested videos
so I can see different ways in which the
traffic found my video and actually
watched it here I could see externally
how people were able to find my videos
and I could see 46% found it via Google
search see some lots of information here
uh about sources of traffic how the
traffic got to these videos so I could
see then once the traffic found my
videos how many times they actually saw
it and viewed it and then watched it so
that's how many times I was able to
reach viewers via different sources and
then their reaction to that how many
times they saw it and watched it here I
can click on interest viewers so again I
could see the top videos in terms of
watch time I could see the top playlist
list so here I can see my partners
playlist was the top playlist so I can
see some interest here in terms of
average view duration and then here we
have build an audience so we can look at
specific audiences if we have them built
in YouTube to see how many people
actually watch my videos so here I can
see 88% of the people who watched my
videos over the last 28 days were not
even subscribed so that tells me a lot
of people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them but they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to home in
on how your videos are performing so if
you have any additional questions about
YouTube analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some indepth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spy tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a premium tool like Sprout social to
listen in on our competitors we can use
another fremium tool social blade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well MZ we
looked at Moz earlier for keyword or
organic mod is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and Buzz Sumo so that's
another freemium tool again there are
lots of tools out there these are just
examples of some of the tools that we
use here to Simply learn I use
personally and professionally to get a
sense of what our competition's doing so
why would we want to use a competitor
spine tool well it may sound like a very
straightforward question but there are
lots of reasons why and so let's look at
some of these reasons and the first
reasons we really want to identify you
know our competitor backlinks and
monitor changes in the ranking so the
reason why we have this is the top
bullet point is because SEO organic
search is a long-term strategy on page
off page website very technical and
creative there's a lot going on with SEO
a lot going on and sometimes it takes a
long time to rank for something and a
lot of SEO does depend on relevancy
relevancy being how many quality back
links are linked to you so it's always
good to leverage what your competitors
are doing so you could see how you stack
up and so that's why this is up there as
number one we want to be able to really
take a look at what our competitors are
doing another example would be hey how
much uh traffic a competitor is gaining
on certain keywords this could go either
way for paid search organic search what
are comp editors bidding on are they
really getting traffic from those
keywords so there are tools out there
that help us Leverage What are
competitions doing okay we can also
identify our competitors top performing
content for Relevant topics okay we can
determine what our competitor's website
referral traffic is okay we can pull our
competitor's data and compare it with
our own campaigns so lots of tools out
there to help you do this and we may
want to track the total amount of clicks
a competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go and
take a look at a few examples how we can
leverage all these bullet points that we
just discussed and so we're going to
start out with Sprout social and Sprout
social is a tool I use it's a social
media platform there's a lot of things
you can do with Sprout social definitely
generate reports for your social media
platforms you could set up post that get
published at a certain time and day
there's also one particular tool in here
called listening and so what we could do
is we just put in for example RV rentals
in Twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about RV rentals so we could do
this for Twitter we could do it Facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on Sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put put in
a brand name we're just going General
here because we want to rank for the
keyword RV rentals and so here we could
take a look at you know what some of
these particular brands are doing like
go RV rentals Cruise America RV we could
see just scroll down and we can get a
sense of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting TW or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay I can get a sense of
everything about this tweet and so here
I can scroll down and I can see what's
been shared by other people for this
particular brand and I can see a lot of
people are as an example Le retweeting
this particular giveaway and so to me it
just gives me a sense in this particular
example on Twitter as to what are
competitors doing okay let's turn our
attention to SEO so remember at first
bullet point we want to get a sense of
what our competitors are doing when it
comes to back blinks and so Moz has a
great tool called link Explorer and Link
Explorer there allows us to actually
compare link profiles so for my domain I
can go ahead and put my competitor's
domains in there and definitely get a
sense of you know how many links my
competitors have external inter internal
I can get a sense of the domain
Authority I can get a sense of page
Authority linking domains so I can
really do a a comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this this gives me an
overview of everything I need to know
organically now Moz also has another
great tool under link Explorer called
link intersect and I like link intersect
I use it a lot because if our
competitors really have a number of
external links and domains pointing to
their site and they have a better domain
Authority and Page Authority then you
know I want to be able to you know see
what they're doing where they're linking
who's linking to them I want to get be
able to get a snapshot of why is their
domain so much better than ours in terms
of authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so I can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then I can find
Opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you could see where my
site intersects with their site and if
it doesn't actually intersect then I
have an opportunity to actually try and
get a link on that particular site so
that's what the link intersect report
does it allows me to see where my links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then I have an
opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the L link intersect
tool is in mods it allows me to really
get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and where my competitor linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another report under Moz is
link Explorer and the discovered and
lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitor's domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within mods
we can get a good snapshot of what
websites are linking to our competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites and
specifically what sites so the whole
idea is if it's good for our competitors
meaning they're linking from a site that
has good domain Authority and low spam
score then it's probably a site I want
to be able to tackle as well okay so you
have discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in maz's
link Explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in MZ and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitor's
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain Authority
is Page Authority for the homepage but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9,000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain Authority I could sort
by domain Authority where these pages
are being linked from and so here I can
see reddit reddit reddit so a lot of
Reddit here which is a good site for
back back Link in New York Times so you
know there's a lot of different U sites
here Washington Post so I can get a good
snapshot of my competitor by seeing
every link that's pointing to them now
of course I don't want to go through
9,000 links I can really just hone in on
a specific link Source or link type or
link state so I can really filter it if
I wanted to I can export the report and
do some further analysis but really the
whole idea here as I can see what URL is
linking to this particular competitor
site with the anchor text is what the
page and domain Authority is so this
gives me a really really good Insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need need to be on
Reddit because if that's where our
competitor is and they're getting good
link juice from Reddit which has a
domain authority of 90 then hey if it's
good for the goose it's good for the
gander so they say so inbound links is
just another good report you can
leverage in MZ under the link Explorer
reporting tool now if I want to get a
good snapshot as to what my competitor
is doing on search exactly well look no
further than spy Fu so spyfu is a
another tool that you can leverage from
a PPC SEO perspective you know from an
SEO perspective you got some backlinking
data as well just like you did in MZ
from a PPC perspective you can get some
good keyword insights and so here I just
went ahead and typed in the domain and
what this is going to do is just give me
an overall snapshot for my competitor's
domain so here I could see you know how
many organic keywords they're found for
the estimated monthly SEO clicks they're
getting based on the volume of those
keywords okay I can see here the
keywords their top competitors also rank
for the rank history 12 years so this
particular domain's been around a long
time okay so that's on the organic side
I can flip over to the paid side and I
could see that they are doing paid
search I could see 5,000 plus keywords
they're bidding on based on that what
they're actually paying and then I could
see you know some of the other
competitors listed here from a paid
perspective and an organic perspective I
could see the shared keyword overlap
okay now again you can pay for this
because it's premium and get some really
good insights as to how your domain
compares to your competitors so I'm
using the free version and here the free
version spyfu is just giving me some
overall data on the specific domain I
entered in and so I entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is Google ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you could see some
even some Google ads history I can see
exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then I can see some organic ranking
history here as I keep scrolling down
this overview report so I can see for RV
rent where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz spy
fu is providing me with some insight as
to hey what links are pointing to them
and what the domain strength is and how
many clicks they expect to receive so
this is all free data take it or leave
it but it's all free data available to
you under spyfu so spy few gives you
kind of an overview for free some really
in-depth analysis if you actually pay
for it and it just really hones in on
what your competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic wise and so spy fu is a really
good tool to leverage if you just want
to get a snapshot of how your competitor
uh overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to Google analytics because in
Google analytics under audience I can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous sta so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
is sharing
8,863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8,000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
as others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our local and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're going
to go with
4,99 9 and so we could see there are
about you know 300 something web
properties contributing 47 web
properties now contributing to this
report so if we're focused on the New
Zealand region and this is the amount of
traffic we get we're now comparing us
against 47 other Anonymous web
properties so now if I go back to the
report after I've honed in I'm looking
at channels and I could see how many
sessions we're getting by channels and
how I can
against the competition I can also
measure up against percentage of new
sessions new users pages per session
average session duration bounce rate but
that's just channels I can also do
location and devices so the whole idea
behind this report is yes you're not
honing in on a particular competitor but
you're honing in on your industry so
you're getting a good idea as to how you
compare against your industry just by
making some adjustments in the
benchmarking report you obviously want
to make sure you're looking at the same
industry adjust for your country or
region adjust for the site size meaning
how many sessions you actually get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest they'll compare you against
those in your industry and so I find
this to be a good tool because it allows
me to stack up our site against those in
the industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a
keyword and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I can see some organic search
results okay if I scroll down I'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same keyword meaning they're
paying for RV rentals so if I clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay Google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually trying
to rank for this keyword or trying to be
found for this keyword so that's all I
did I just did a search now from an
organic perspective if you really want
to hone in on your competition you can
always do the syntax all and title colon
and then hit enter so now I could see I
have 163,000 results and what does that
tell me that tells me that I have
163,000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have
163,000 different listings ahead of you
that you need to jump over in order to
rank for the keyword RV rentals so using
the All entitle syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keyword so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax
and you can see for RV rentals I have
132 million but that's not really
accurate because not all these listings
have the keyword RV rentals in the title
Tag and Title tag if you're working on
organic search is one of the key
important factors for ranking so you
need to have that keyword in the title
tag so that's the whole idea behind
using the All and title syntax it gives
us a good ideas to what our
competition's doing and how many sites
we have to jump over to get to number
one on Google Now if you're running
Google ads just as we did with RV
rentals we went out there and we saw we
typed that in as a query and we saw how
many advertisers there were for RV
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and what auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year-to dat and here we can see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
can see impression share so for if we're
talking about one keyw every keyword has
100% impression share how much of that
impression share share are you getting
and when we say impression share meaning
eyeballs when we talk about eyeballs are
we getting a majority of the eyeballs or
our competitors getting majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position I can see how often I overlap
with my competitors okay I could see how
often I'm above a particular competitor
I could see what percentage I'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then I
can see how often I outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so I can see all
this good insight as to what competitors
are bidding on the same keywords I am
okay so this is if you're running Google
ads okay so if you're running Google ads
okay you can just click on the auction
insights report you can find that the
top navigation just by clicking on
campaigns and by doing so you'll be able
to gain some insights as to where you
stack up from a paid search perspective
against your competitors so let's turn
our attention to paid marketing tools so
if you're doing some advertising on
Google Bing LinkedIn you probably want
to work within those platforms as the
tool of choice so you know if you're
doing paid search on say Google
search.com or display you could be doing
display advertising on you know a
network like ad r or Google or you could
be doing social media paid ads say on
Facebook so whatever it is you're doing
you probably want to work within that
platform itself to get the ideal data
that you need okay so here are some of
the tools some of the places you can go
of course if you work in Google ads you
also have Google ads editor that you can
leverage okay and I'll show you that in
a couple minutes you have Google ads
Keyword Planner of course both of the
these are paid if you're running
campaigns okay so Bing if you're running
campaigns on Bing okay you get all this
good data that you can digest through
some reporting okay you also have some
third party tools out there that you
also have to pay for in wordstream okay
so wordstream is a thirdparty tool that
you can leverage Bing and Google are
actual advertising Network so you would
advertise on the platform itself and get
all the data you need right in the
platform and leverage a lot of the tools
that they have available in the platform
as I mentioned you could also use Google
ads editor uh so Bing also has their own
editor as well so and as well as
Facebook so you can use an editor type
version and I'll show you that here in a
couple minutes but let's talk about why
we want to use the tools in the platform
itself well we want to be able to
monitor how our ads performing so which
ad receives the most traffic as an
example we want to identify keywords
that are performing for us okay so our
keywords converting not converting or
they cost us a lot of money and not
netting a high enough return for us so
we want to keep an eye on that okay so
we want to monitor our cost okay across
different locations and devices not only
cost but we want to also monitor how our
ads are performing across different
locations of devices key words across
different locations and devices so we
want to be able to measure by device
okay so we also want to analyze
competitor's data and as we showed you
in the competitor section Google as an
example has auction insights reporting
analytics has benchmarking so Google
itself does provide some information in
the case of auction insights as to how
uh your competitors are performing
against you on Google search so that's
on the paid search side then you have
display okay so display advertisements
okay you're across a different network
so there are different types of networks
out there for example ad roll okay you
have cr SRA is another paid version of
or paid tool you can use in wide orbit
so these are some of the paid marketing
tools you can leverage of course I like
to stay if I'm advertising on Google I
like to stay uh in Google ads and
measure my display performance that way
but if you're on ad roll for example
then you want to leverage ad rolles
reporting platform and some of the tools
they have to offer so if we look at
display why do we want to leverage some
of these tools well just like search for
example where we want to look at keyword
and AD performance same kind of concept
here we want to be able to monitor
whether we have the right keywords and
right customer engagement so when when
it comes to display we want to be able
to make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
Target insights as well are we reaching
the Right audience when it comes to
display and Google has a good breakdown
that I'm going to be able to show you
here in a couple minutes okay so we want
to improve our campaigns by monitoring
our competitor display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that and that's on the display
side and if we look at Social okay why
what tools can we use on social well you
got Facebook ads manager okay you got
add espresso qu tweey you got all these
cool paid search tools again I usually
stick with where I'm advertising so if
I'm advertising on LinkedIn or Twitter
I'm going to leverage that platform but
just know that there are other tools
available for you so a social like
display it's all about targeting our
audience so for these some of the tools
like on Facebook we can review and
relaunch our ad campaigns based on
target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights in this
example about Facebook users how are our
users per interacting with our ads and
then we want to Target People based on
their activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel pre preferences Etc
so social allows us to do that and then
with Facebook as example we can monitor
any AB test we run for example if we're
running call to action test we can
measure the results of that right in
Facebook and I'm going to show you an
example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into Google ads and look at
some tools available to us from the
search side of the house so if we're
running search campaigns W in Google ads
we could see campaign data we could see
keyword data we could see add data so
for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks
clickthrough rates Etc and so that way I
can go ahead and pause ads activate ads
so that's right here in the Google ads
uh platform itself now if I want to look
at specific keywords I can do that so I
can see what keywords are driving
traffic and clicks here I can just sort
by clicks and now I can see not only
what keywords are driving clicks I could
see what the click theate is I can see
the Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm bidding on I
could see how much I've paid by keyword
and more importantly I want to be able
to see conversions or conversion rate
and then with Google ads you have
quality scores so we want to be able to
measure quality score so this is uh
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in
and based on the keyword that somebody
typed in as a query I can see what match
type triggered that particular ad and so
if I see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or
want my ad shown for then I can go ahead
and just select it and I can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in Google ads
okay and then you have the auction
Insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive ative analysis and so here
if we look at the auction insights we'll
be able to adjust our date range and
we'll be able to see basically you know
who else is bidding on the keywords and
what their impression share is what
their average position is what the
overlap rate is position above rate top
of page absolute top of page right and
out ranking share so once we at Google
has data then they'll be able to share
that information with you okay so that's
just key words but there's a cool tool
that I really like and I leverage it for
SEO and paperclick and that's Google's
Keyword Planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on Keyword Planner
we'll be able to Leverage The Keyword
Planner and the whole idea behind the
Keyword Planner is do we want to
discover new keywords or for the
keywords we have selected we can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
kind of volume I'm going to get and how
much I can expect to pay so now once
I've added my keyword to that plan I can
go ahead and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of $2 so I can go ahead and
adjust my plan accordingly if I want to
in order to see basically how much I can
expect to spend so that's the whole idea
behind the Keyword Planner in terms of
choosing new keywords and once you
choose keywords you're interested and
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
Impressions you can expect to get and if
you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of Google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
many different tools and features within
Google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so really I'm just going to
highlight some of the more important
tools and features so I mentioned the
Keyword Planner I mentioned the
campaigns keywords and ads reports
another thing I would look at in Google
ads again we mentioned this as one of
our key defining why would we use it
bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use Google ads reporting tool
because we want to look at devices and
we want to be able to see what devices
are driving traffic from what campaign
and then the cool thing about Google ads
is right in Google ads platform you can
go ahead and do a bid adjustment so if I
increase my bid adjustment for example
on mobile phones then my particular ad
in this particular campaign is going to
show more than on computer so I can
always decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
right in Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices while you also
have locations too so we mentioned that
as one of the reasons why we want to use
some of these tools and if I see a
particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bid
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned in search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads Ed editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your C with your
campaigns on locally so you're making
changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I can see the ad groups here okay so for
example I just wanted to turn off all
these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status enabled
to pause and I can rever back if I want
to okay so you can make household
changes so here I could see the campaign
the ad group level if I choose an add
group then I can see some keyword and
again I can make changes at nauseum here
I can copy I can paste I can delete okay
so I can make a lot of changes really
quick right in Google ads editor and
that's the whole point of editor is to
go ahead and work locally while somebody
else is working locally on the same
account you could both be working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent changes so if I
say get recent changes to all campaigns
what Google editor is going to do is
contact Google ads in the cloud and
download all those changes so here I can
see the changes being download in editor
from Google ads and when it's done it's
going to highlight all the changes that
have been made and so once I'm done
reviewing those changes I can go ahead
and click done and now I know I have the
recent latest changes in editor so now I
can go ahead and continue to make some
changes and when I'm done making changes
I can go ahead and post them so that's
the beauty of Google ads editor Bing has
a version Facebook has a version it
allows you to again go with the keyword
level the ad group level okay you can
look at ads itself and make changes to
the ads okay you can do a lot of
different things right an editor in fact
you could do pretty much most of what
you can do in Google ads you can do in
Google ads editor and so that's Google
ads Editor to me I would recommend it if
you're experienced with Google ads again
it's software you have to download it
you're going to use it on your computer
as software but when you make changes
all you need to do is post those changes
or get recent changes that have been
made on Google ads and so that's Google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into Google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network
but the platform is still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search Network as well as for
the Display Network writing Google ads
so if I want to take a look at a
campaign and AD group on the Display
Network I can just click on that ad
group and I can look at the ads that are
running for that particular ad group on
the Display Network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
Network you can only use text ads so
here I can look at image ads and I can
see how they're performing in fact you
could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so Google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
Impressions click the rate Etc right on
on my ads and extensions report in
Google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we targeting here okay so when
this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up what audience is performing
best okay so here I can see a Breakout
by audience again I can see the same me
metrics I could see on the search side I
could see clicks Impressions click the
rate more importantly I want to be able
to measure conversions okay so that's
the whole idea when you're in these
platforms and you're paying for ads is
you want to be able to measure against
conversions and you can also measure
against cost per conversion conversion
rate okay so those are some key metrics
to measure up against whether it's
audience keyword ad whatever the
dimension is so here on the Display
Network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
Network the Display Network allows us to
see demographic data and so now I could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that Google provides us and I
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks Impressions Etc including
conversions so you also have the
opportunity on the Display Network to
keywords you have the opportunity to add
topics and you have the opportunity to
see placements or run placements so here
if I click on where ADS have shown I can
actually see where my ads have shown up
for this display campaign and Google ads
allows you the ability to go ahead and
you can exclude it from the ad group or
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action on a
specific placement and I can see the
type of placement whether it's a mobile
app whether it's a site I can go ahead
and see exactly where that placement was
so that's the placements report you have
demographics you have audiences you have
keywords you have all these different
reports available to you on the Google
ads platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising I
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on Google ads Okay
so take a look at the Google ads
tutorial we have set up on YouTube okay
if you search for Google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good uh tutorial on
everything related to Google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you you could see just how
powerful it is and all the different
features that are available so take a
look at the video it's a nice
complimentary video to this one this
digital marketing tools and this will
give you a nice in deeper insight into
everything that's available on Google
ads and if you have any tools or
features on Google ads whether it's the
search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into uh
Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we can see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we can see our
adets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have left side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two adets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and then
I can see the cost per click here at $1
as an example and so now I can go in and
I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the creat cre is I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has uh
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you could see
here I could see some standard reports
by add add set age and gender and then I
can see all reports here listed out by
placement by placement and device time
of day country Etc so if we just look at
age and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so you
could see by campaign I'm looking at all
campaigns here and I'm looking at just
age and gender I can certainly deselect
one of these and I can look at a
specific time range so now I could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here I could see 35 to 44 female I could
see the reach and Impressions and how
often they're actually seeing my ad now
this is key for Facebook because if
somebody's seeing your ad a lot they're
probably going to tune out to it so
that's what makes the frequency metric
so important on Facebook because then we
can go ahead and you know turn off that
particular age and gender if we needed
to and we can see how much we spent so
this just gives you some idea of the
type of reporting that's available in
Facebook ads manager now the great thing
about Facebook uh reporting an ads
manager is you know I can group or
ungroup uh my Dimensions if I needed to
I could change the view and arrange
columns I can get rid of columns just as
you would in Google ads reporting very
similar stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you can pick and choose as
well okay and you got lots of different
flexibility when you're looking at the
reports on how your campaigns are
performing now here I can pick and
choose I can choose campaign adset ads
objective again I can choose different
demographics so I have a lot of options
available to me in terms of how I want
to you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my
adset or my ad now remember if you're in
Facebook you can always go in and edit
the campaign you can edit the adset
remember in the adset that's where a lot
of your decisions are going to be made
including how you want to drive the
traffic okay what your budget is okay
you can basically choose your audience
here so you're going to be able to
choose what type of campaign it's going
to be and based on that campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the ation the
age range the gender so all of this is
going to be set up in the ad set or the
campaign or the ad if you go ahead and
edited ad remember you can do AB testing
as well so you have a lot of different
options and features available to you
writing ads manager when you're managing
your paid search campaigns on Facebook
so if you want some more information
about all the different features and
tools and Facebook ads manager check out
the Facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year in addition you can also look at
another one that we did on Facebook
called Facebook advertising tips and
strategies so that should give you some
sense of everything related to Facebook
ads and how to take advantage of the
Facebook ads manager platform so if
there's anything on social that we may
have missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention to affiliate
marketing lot of affiliate marketing
platforms out there the number one
probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ they're an affiliate
platform they have an premium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically you're going to have to move
on and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click Inc AWI
so a lot of these are Brokers per se and
when I say Brokers like for example with
CJ you as a merchant or you as a
publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you need really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and and a lot of lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually going
to take a look at CJ and go through some
of the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know Affiliates
inflows employees
other Advocates you want to partner with
so again you could be on the merchant
side you could be actually selling a
product and you're going to want
somebody to help you sell that product
somebody with a website who's an
influencer who drives a lot of traffic
to their own site who you know does sell
reputable brand Etc so you need somebody
to help you introduce you to these sites
okay so CJ and some of these other
marketing platforms affiliate marketing
platforms do that okay so these tools
are there to do the introductions the
brokering the relationship so the other
benefit here is you can contract with
Affiliates and track the traffic and
conversions well what do I mean by that
well if you do use cj.com by no means am
I only endorsing that platform there are
plenty others out there but whatever
platform you use you're going to want to
be able to set up terms and conditions
with that particular ular affiliate so
you could set up a terms and conditions
for say 10% off all sales as an example
okay well you're going to need a
platform that will help you broker that
contract okay contract terms or program
terms furthermore you're going to need a
platform to help you track hey is this
affiliate helping me drive traffic or is
this affiliate driving traffic to my
products and is this affiliate helping
me sell so these platforms help you do
just that okay okay so you can gain High
website rankings with the help of your
affiliate meaning that hey your
affiliate can be promoting your product
and if they're promoting your product
you have a chance to show up via paid
search organic search off other websites
so social so you have a lot of benefits
to working with affiliate marketing in
itself and the tools available will help
you gain website rankings as one example
who we want to be able to track certain
metrics okay so an affiliate marking you
have earnings per click EPC as an
example most platforms measure EPC from
a 7day period to a 3mon period okay you
can also figure out what the actual cost
per click is just like you do on say
Google search you can actually measure
that in affiliate okay you want to
eliminate fraudulent clicks Impressions
and conversions so any AFF
platform worth its weight is going to
help you understand you know how many
pressions and clicks and conversions
you're getting and help you manage that
in terms of fraudulent clicks or hey if
you're getting a lot of Impressions and
no clicks that's a problem too so these
platforms are really built on helping
you manage your relationship with the
affiliate by offering up all sorts of
reports and tools you know the other big
benefit here to affiliate marketing tool
is hey we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody see our product did
somebody click on our product did
somebody go into the shopping cart with
our product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience it's similar to
yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publishers link so we're going to click
on the Publishers link and remember when
you sign up Publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember
you could set up your own program term
for any publisher so as a best practice
if you have Publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know These Guys these Publishers get
better program terms versus say other
Publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful on the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
Publishers is performing well sweeten
the deal offer them a better program
terms and so you can align Publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
Publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get aligned
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now we want to manage by status
instead of by program terms we could see
all the different organizations we have
in our Network these are our Publishers
we're the affiliate we're the ones
selling the product we want to know
who's selling who's not selling and so
we can look at all our Publishers by
program terms or by status okay so
basically you could see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last basically 7 days or three
months so you can look at basically how
your Publishers are performing just by
clicking on manage by status here in
cj.com so when you're looking at reports
in cj.com or really any other affiliate
program you might see the acronym EPC
this stands for earnings per click
actually it's a little misleading it's
actually earnings per 100 clicks so
basically CJ calculates you know how
much your publisher is actually making
per click you know just like paid search
we're paying Google X amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these Publishers can't make any money if
they don't generate clicks so that's why
you have an EPC model or metric so to
speak so you can measure earnings per
click CJ does it over 7 a period and
over a 3mon period so you could sort
based on 7day or 3 month to see see
who's earning the most per click in
terms of Publishers now you can select
under Publishers groups now you can
group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea behind affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be a
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get aligned with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are best performing Publishers or
by region
or you know by promotion I mean how you
group your Publishers is totally up to
you however take advantage of the option
to create publisher groups because the
whole idea again I'm going to repeat it
is you want to get Publishers and you
want to start building your base of
Publishers because the more Publishers
you have the more chance you are to sell
your product remember if nobody clicks
on your product then nobody's going to
buy your product so if you have
Publishers who are promoting your
product for you then you have a good
opportunity to sell it so the more
Publishers you have on board the better
the opportunity so now once you have
Publishers you can start grouping these
Publishers accordingly to whatever makes
sense it's a business decision just know
the options available in CJ to group
Publishers let's turn our attention to
social media marketing tools social
media always a great topic to talk about
so we're going finish up all our digital
marketing tools with social media we
talked about SEO paid competition
affiliate email you know web analytics
it's just appropriate to finish up with
social media because social media has so
many tools available so many okay the
first one I can think about here is hoot
site hoot site is a great social media
marketing tool to use okay it's a
premium okay you can set up a free trial
here you you basically a base account
and then uh you can use hoot site to do
a lot of things anything from setting up
ly pages to actually publishing content
to listening hoot tweet to me is one of
the most powerful social media marketing
tools available you got buffer buffer is
a paid version but you can actually set
up a low cost or free account actually
on Buffer and then move to a paid
account okay you got tweet deck been
around a long time that is actually free
and I would recommend tweet deck and
we're going to take a look at that here
in a couple minutes okay and then you
got Sprout social Sprout social is
another social marketing platform
similar to hoot week do a lot of
reporting a lot of publishing you can a
lot of listening and so we're going to
take a look at Sprout social today as
well before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective you're pumping
out a lot of content so you need to be
able to smart
efficiently you know schedule and manage
your post okay so you're not just
working likely with just one platform
like Facebook you're probably on a
number of different platforms depending
on your business depending on your
bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products Etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be Instagram Pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything in one place then these
social media marketing platforms need to
be able to make it easy for you to add
and manage different accounts okay so a
lot of them have the ability for you to
add you know not just one Twitter
account but multiple Twitter accounts
and not just one social media platform
but multiple social media platforms and
a good social media marketing tool worth
its weight will help you monitor the
results so so monitor social media posts
that help Drive leads and sales in other
words you're going to have a lot of
different metrics associated with each
social media marketing platform okay
which one is actually doing its job okay
so you want to be able to easily manage
these platforms applications and
websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log into each
platform you just log into one place get
a sense of what's been posted what the
engagement is did they purchase Etc and
what you want to do is be able to
individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to go
ahead and customize a post depending on
what that post is depending on what the
product is what time of day what target
market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual post on Real Time data so if
for example you post something youing
one of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprout social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that platform
is going to have its own metrics if you
will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insight so
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent post so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads he you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log into Sprout social I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log in in Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I can see Impressions by
day you know a lot lot of the same
material same information is already in
Facebook insights so if it's available
in Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other you using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do can schedule it
for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go wa schedule so this is on
Twitter okay so you know we could choose
another platform here it's just that
easy to schedule so you want to be able
to schedule accordingly because again
when you schedule something then you
want to look at the behavior of it so
it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on once something got published you can
see the reaction of it and react to it
so another thing here that I like about
is about social heat site a lot of these
other platforms do it really well you
got listening tools so you can listen in
on conversations that are being had for
example uh mail delivery you know if we
do mail delivery on Twitter search we'll
be able to see what's been tweeted about
mail deliveries you know that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is Sprout social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar to sprout social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1:15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and and I can
view it on a calendar I can add a label
for it so that's another benefit to
later is that they have this media
library here they have conversations so
I can actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being had similar to The Listening tool
in Sprout social and they have analytics
so you can actually see right in
later.com how your particular social
media platform is performing so I can
see it here over 7 days I can see the
number of followers have increased I can
see the growth rate I can see the number
of Impressions that I've received okay
so I want to be able to see how my
particular platform's performing over a
period of time so I can look at reach a
lot of profile views website clicks okay
so I can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform of later
you can look at specific post
performance so we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments Impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use a hashtag
you can actually see how many times the
hashtag has been used or saved how many
Impressions it's received okay so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet deck so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notification
I can see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
could see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific Okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see the
you got the Cricket World Cup you got
you know the soccer football World Cup
going on so you know we could pick a a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging or using
that hash Friday feeling in their tweets
and so the whole idea behind you know
tweet deck it it serves up a interesting
overview so to speak of not only your
account but you know a specific topic or
what's trending or you know other things
that are being said so if you really
want to pay attention to your brand or
something really specific like you know
your competitors or a specific product
then you can just do a search on that
and so that's the great thing about
tweak deck it allows you to kind of just
look and listen in on everything going
on in Twitter now we do have a good
video out here on YouTube how to start
social media marketing so if you haven't
had a chance to look at it take a look
it goes over some of these tools that we
cover today like Sprout social later.com
you know Facebook insights so it does
cover in more detail some of what we
covered on these social media marketing
tools so take a look at how to start
social media marketing so we covered a
lot of different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plugin if you will so I can go and take
a look at a spec a specific video and
see how many hours it's been watched how
many views minutes watched subscribers
Etc you know the great thing here I can
look at the entire entire account so I
can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid IQ extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because is good for
video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content on your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool
maybe a third party tool to give some
objective reasoning as to what more we
can be doing so you got tools like SEO
site checkup or site analyzer these are
pay tools but you know if you're really
heavily invested in SEO then they may
pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third party tool so these are good tools
to use used for Content optimization you
know there's also other key Reddit but
you know there's Keyword Planner uh in
Google there's also uh word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a Google
ads platform and so if you don't have
Google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to Google's Keyword Planner
so having a thirdparty keyword tool will
pay dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only paper cck but also SEO and if
you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in Social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
Reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in Google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts SEO so
there are other tools available you you
got a third party tool here that's free
solar winds pingdom you actually have
page feed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of in determining how you can
improve your page lad time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimization so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
zaret okay so I'm going to show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log into hotjar.com you can set up
an account it's actually free and with
the free account you can have hot jar
measure the Heat map not only the heat
map but the click mapping the scrolling
of a particular page and so here you can
see we're looking at a particular page
here so hot jar allows me to you know
see on that page where people are
clicking um I can also see where people
are moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you can see here on the page I can see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking most
mostly if I switch over to move mode
then I can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
Mouse and then I have my scroll analysis
so I could see you know how far down
people actually scroll on the page and
so again with a paid account you can
measure up to 10,000 page views with the
free version you can measure up to 2,000
page views and so 2,000 Pags allows you
to get some insight as to what people
are clicking on where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so I definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hot jar so hotjar.com is a
tool I would recommend as well so one
final tool and I'd be a remiss if I
didn't mention it and that's Google
optimize so Google optimize is a Google
platform that allows you to AB test and
so AB testing means that you have you
have an original page and you're
changing one element on that page to see
which one performs better and so with
Google optimize it's just very easy to
set up to run and the whole point of
Google optimize and AB testing is to
improve website performance so here you
can see I have an account set up and
optimize you can see we're running one
test here and we're just testing one
element versus the original so we move
photos to the top of the page the
original didn't have the photos to the
top of the page and so we can go into
reporting here Google optimize does all
the heavy lifting and so here you could
see we can look at bounces or we can
look at you know basically a measure the
test up against the metric that's
important to our business and again the
whole point is to improve website
performance and so definitely take a
look at Google optimize we'll have
another webinar in the future on the
topic but you know to me Google
optimizes free you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests then that means you have
the ability to really improve website
performance okay so Google optimize is a
tool that I would recommend today we're
going to talk about why you would want
to rank using SEO and SEO is search
engine optimization also known as
organic search you also may as he a say
organic listings but we're going to talk
a little bit about why You' want to rank
your we site in organic search okay what
is search engine optimization then we're
going to follow that up with how does
Google rank websites so why does it rank
one website over another and how do we
get our website to rank number one then
we're going to talk about the different
types of SEO or search engine
optimization techniques so you can get
your website ranked number one and then
we're going to finish that off with the
dos and don'ts of
SEO staying ah ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading un
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here